britain is mourning the death of prince
philip husband to queen elizabeth
he died on friday morning aged 99. today
military guns will fire salutes and
sporting events will pause for minutes
of silence flags will fly at half-mast
until the day of his funeral which is
yet to be announced
although buckingham palace has asked
crowds not to gather and lay flowers
during the pandemic people have been
coming out to express their grief
it's been a year filled with pain and
isolation for those in the united
kingdom
with many losing loved ones in the
coronavirus pandemic
but much of british society is pausing
to give special attention to the passing
of one man they hold dear
i have a huge huge amount of respect for
the royal family
um quite emotional actually i'm just
talking about it and
we the news broke as we were walking
through parliament square um
and my daughter and i just first we just
felt like we had to come down here and
just
be near the palace and safely obviously
mosques and everything else
and just be close to the royal family
today oh the prince philip was a
wonderful father and a real asset to
british life and i'm sure the queen
is grieving terribly my wishes to her
very sad i actually shed a tear i felt
really it's we knew it was going to
happen but still very very sad
sad sad he's been with us all through
our lives
as the pair of people in london
make their way to windsor castle or
buckingham palace to pay their respects
to prince philip
the royal family urged people not to
gather in large numbers due
to the pandemic asking them to make a
charitable donation instead
[Music]
westminster abbey's bells ring once
every 99 minutes in tribute
uk prime minister boris johnson says his
thoughts are with the queen
who has lost her husband
so we mourn today with her majesty the
queen
we offer our condolences to her and to
all her family
and we give thanks as a nation and a
kingdom
for the extraordinary life and work
of prince philip duke of edinburgh
the government says flags will fly at
half mast all over the country
until the prince's funeral
his death will also be marked by a 41
gun salute
at noon on saturday
i'm joined now by culture reporter robin
merrill robin
d what do you think the prince philip's
legacy will be
i i think a number of things i think
first of all this extraordinary
life of service as an example to others
i mean
73 years as prince consult
which is a kind of impossible task as
you're always number
two and in his case he was very much a
a masculine man very old school and
having to be
a step behind the queen must have been
difficult for him
he did want to say that he was first
second and last he never wanted to let
her down
and he never did the the other legacy of
course is this fabulous
um duke of edinburgh award
award scheme that he started way
back in 1956 he was a an
environmentalist before his time
really i mean because this was all about
young people
with nature working with nature and the
outdoors and it was it's a scheme that
will
uh has thrived and will continue for
many years to come
he's also been quite a divisive figure
can you tell us a bit more about that
well he certainly has um
um he had an incurable sense of humor
which got him into trouble
i should mention that he he
his start in life wasn't easy when he
was one year
years old his father prince andrew of
greece was banished from his country
because of a coup d'etat
when he was seven his mother was
diagnosed as a schizophrenic and
unfortunately was put in an asylum and
he saw very little of her
for the rest of his life but um
in in this age of political correctness
he was of course
famous for some of his gaffes
very dry sense of humor i was often
amused by him
and he was very irreverent and of course
some of the things he said are quite
unrepeatable um
he didn't suffer fools gladly but
actually my brother was prince charles's
private secretary for some time and had
dealings with the duke of edinburgh and
he said one thing to me
he didn't reveal much to me because i
was a journalist but he did say he was
very relaxed within himself
and that was his character he
he didn't mind about everybody else now
of course
thoughts obviously with the queen um by
her own admission philip was
such a rock for her in what must have
been quite a lonely
role indeed
she called him her strength and stay
didn't she have one speech
it was said that he was the only man the
only person in the world
who could treat her and talk to her
normally
and she did adore him and i mean despite
the fact that the queen must have
expected this he's just spent the
longest time
ever in hospital in his entire life he
was a very fit man his entire life
um she must have expected this i think
as as we all know
when the moment happens it really does
hit you and i suspect she's been hit
very hard i mean
they they were together for three
quarters of a century
yeah it's quite hard to imagine all
right robin merrill thank you very much
you